hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to resident evil 2 now I am
a little bit sick I'm on the recovering
end of a flu or a cold there's something
like that but I'm feeling better now and
I'm feeling good enough to record this
game but if I'm a little sluggish I'm a
little out of my mind it's because I'm
hopped up on cold medicine and I'm going
a little insane now there's an option to
play as either Leon or Claire and I
imagine that there are two facets of the
same story so I'm just gonna go with
what was first Leon here Oh
hardcore hmm well I don't need to I'm
not a big bubble on baby so I don't need
assisted mode I think I'll just go
standard cuz that seems good to me
I like standard Moana so let's do this
let's see what awaits us in the
okay last Friday night I was walking
home from the bar this woman started
coming towards me she's staggering you
know so I figured she was drunk okay
tell us be honest now how many drinks
did you have no man I barely had a buzz
on oh c'mon look just listen
alright she got closer and I got a good
look at her yet is he her eyes her nose
it's like shelter the corpse sounds like
my wife hey you gotta stay strong don't
give in to fear out there right just
getting good
I need some sleep
[Applause]
mmm
first blood goes to a truck driver huh
good job buddy
probably a zombie probably hopefully
wasn't huh well no good for nobody
Claire
Oh Oh
now I haven't played the original
Resident Evil 2 so I have no idea how
close this is to the intro story of it
or what I really don't know but I'm
curious right I'm curious how much they
just recreated how much they actually
took new Liberty on cuz it's fascinating
either way of areas well there is all
there's our boy so handsome hey I like
your butt chin it's very cute alright
whatever you carry on you can't harm me
that's a little weird
haha called it see we're like two peas
in a pod do you and I we're gonna be
good friends soon we're gonna be good
friends huh somebody spilled jam
everywhere that's no good oh I'm so
excited so I'm so excited I'm so excited
hello hi hey you got a shotgun or
anything in here I'm probably gonna need
like a shotgun shear if all right
whatever you say man this looks like the
gas station from I wanna be toast I want
to be the bread was it I am bread Oh No
so I answered so unbelievably happy
there I'm here hello mister until dawn
looking teenager guy something's not
right
no no is it your special police skills
that makes you think that the blood on
the floor rain right
that's someone else's breathing hello Oh
hmm all right hey buddy buddy don't move
I'll be back for you uh okay thank you
for the Poynting very helpful all right
whoa ha ha ha I love it
come on bring it on what have you got
huh what do you got
monster zombie gonna jump out of me oh I
know how this goes
freeze I'll shoot I really goofed this
one come on Topanga and don't be oh no
oh no he's not dead is he one more for
good measure there we go
Wow come on stay down dude Oh stay down
you know I really goofed this one I feel
like this is my fault
because you had that completely handled
and then I had to come in here and ruin
everything
so I mean that's entirely my fault oh
hello hey I know I got my priorities
right oh hello okay storage room key you
got it baby uh-huh
inventory huh okay everything is a-okay
I don't feel any remorse whatsoever okay
hey easy peasy lemon squeeze me it sure
is this whole like quiet walk he um oh I
okay wait
nice sick moves tight legit moves
you must be Jill I think so Thanks you
can thank me later when we're safe
yeah it's probably not good lie to you
to know I can yell
come on
[Applause]
now it's a lot of Hope in the now just
you know have the key in it and turn on
like that wait you're a cop
yeah Leon Kennedy you are clear
I live around here no looking for my
brother
he's a cocktail
well it's a good thing we found each
other I don't know what to expect
anymore yeah a little peculiar yeah not
so uh not so good what's happening in
this city how the weather
well weathers real messed up yeah hey
anyway you got boyfriend hello oh no
whoa
I love interest sequences
[Music]
very interesting
no I'm just so excited about this game I
was wondering about this - because remix
usually remakes don't go over so good
but for some reason this remake I've
been unbelievably excited for I think
it's just because Resident Evil 7 like
raise the bar of Resident Evil games
really high and then when they're they
were remake and readers aren't evil to
like with this still having third-person
but I mean it's not like the independent
cameras that are all strung up in the
ceiling but it's interesting
[Music]
police stations not much farther don't
know something
mmm what if we're the only ones if
there's no survivors they're survivors
it's a big city has to be has to be has
to be don't be so stupid
come on now there's got to be survivors
they can't all be horrible zombies I
mean I've done simulations of zombies
infecting cities the more people there
are it always turns out better walking
from here it's just okay yeah uh no just
a regular day in New York huh
[Music]
oh hey I ass
the truck driver shouldn't even that
murder now yeah good luck with that
Oh
oh [ __ ] well that's not good yeah I
would guess the gas would be leaking out
of that thing and not the but giant
truck full of gas oh Claire no Claire Oh
No okay well Claire's gone definitely in
for sure Claire blown to smithereens Oh
okay you got it all right cool
which way do I go this out-of-control
this is nuts
there's Barker's this is bingo Bongo I'm
gonna go down this alley everybody
ignore what's going on there everybody
yeah yeah turned into some have all
become succumb to drugs that's what this
place is absent station what oh okay
yeah I could just climb over the cars
and stuff I'm not I'm not that we can
kind of nimble young and handsome and
full of vigor life okay here we go
excuse you don't need the dog do you I
don't need this pardon me good thing
it's unlocked why would they lock it
why would they lock it in the face of
this horrible city good luck Claire
Claire you ain't getting it here so um
have a good day
oh this is cool ooh hello can i bash
this down there's someone there oh yeah
three people I really shouldn't have
wasted all my bullets on that one guy
but you know how I am when it comes to
stupid we uses of my bullets
I am extremely stupid and my bullets are
very quickly gone okay hello is anybody
here excellent Oh excellent excellent oh
so nice all right gotta save us wait
this is the bomb this is the beast tits
hello it's the same thing as it was
before
there has to be someone here there does
and this time I'm not gonna be rushed
going through this I'm actually gonna
look to try to find the things that I
need to find because if I don't find
them then I'm an idiot
uh-huh okay whatever you say ma'am I got
good feeling about your survival chances
I feel very good about you
okay I'm gonna find that guy Oh
deluxe weapon why why do I get deluxe
weapons I did not order a deluxe edition
okay whatever does he store that away
whoa huh a key why do I need a key
do I need that key do I need this key
Damon this is only for the storage room
right
I would never need this for anything
else here right okay I'm gonna put this
way
bad way and we'll get that later okay
Matilda I'm sorry babe you gotta you
gotta go you gotta go
no here we go let's do this baby all
right sure yeah safe oh this smells real
safe real familiar and real safe
oh yeah the safety and the familiar this
place really smells right hello
alright now this time I'm gonna take my
time there's a fuse something that needs
to be fused did nothing there I mean
there's something in there
oh I see what's going on in there oh oh
you can't get me with the same scares
that you got me before with what with
and such as oh I got this
oh I got it oh I didn't go in here
before whoa
doors magically closed behind me eh well
well well I need to make sure whoa I
need to make sure this is in the two
slot have you beat - all right just in
case just in case you get up which I
have a funny feeling you might whoa
okay good what was this room for some
kind of press conference [ __ ] some
way to get everybody in one room and
then kill them okay whatever I'm leaving
I guess there's some spaghetti on the
table but I'm not feeling like pasta
hello excuse me hard anymore hey yeah
alright well that's different
I don't remember there being a hydrant
here but I do remember there being a
bathroom there's one thing I know it's
barging into women's bathrooms hello
it's me again good to see you good to
see you oh very good to see you good to
see you okay I can only have one of
those ads I'm good to see you okay I saw
it in wipe Raul ooh uh-huh
gross yes don't look so good hmm
you need not rush me sir you need not be
so violently [ __ ] ish you just need
to be calm and collected I am gonna get
to you in due time does I have a funny
feeling it doesn't matter when I get to
you because you're gonna die all the
same yeah a lasat huh
who's there oh I'll get you I'm gonna
get you out I'll get you out or in
Wow
oh that looks like it smarts a little
bit that don't look good
what's a first aid spray we're gonna
spray it on you probably do a little God
is something good to you Friday
something oh you just let me know
let me know when you uh you know when
you think something good here I don't
know what that means but then again I
didn't know what it meant last time so I
guess we're fine anyway you have a good
days are stepping on you a little bit
there come on oh poor big cheongha big
jungle jungle do the towel that's gonna
need some spray or pink we're going you
can't stop me hey you don't cut that
[ __ ] out
now wonder what's through that window
you think I can get through that window
what hey hello buddy and I just want to
get through that window I just want to
see what can I get through here
I can't oh I can not jump no [ __ ] no
that's a big no-no I don't want to be
that oh oh no I did my best I did the
best I could with the last two bullets I
had some of them coming through here
with a lot less than I had previously
yep there you go easy peasy pulling a
bullet left
hi hey buddy hey how you doing
Leon Kennedy there was another officer I
could take my bloody hand come on so you
did what you could come on I've gotta
give you my bloody knife
you want a bloody notebook yeah but
honestly all you need to know is that
this place will eat you alive if you are
careful yeah well I'm supposed to start
last week and I got a call a stay away I
wish I'd come here sooner yeah now
that's all that matters
[Applause]
okay lieutenant I'm ready
hopefully we'll be able to find a way
out of this station
that officer you made earlier Elliott he
thought this secret passageway might do
the trick
hmm
this is good news we can get you to a
hospital
no no I am NOT the priority here
lieutenant I'm not just gonna leave you
here I'm giving you an order
rookie you save yourself first I'd come
with you but I just slow you down
Wow a hero you'll need this I can't take
stop don't make my mistake if you see
one of those things uniform or not you
do not hesitate you take it out or you
run got it yes sir
okay all right good talk man good talk
buddy man he seems so nice
I hope this knife doesn't break because
the last knife that I got was really
crap like real whose real crap like it
was bad
who's grumbling yeah who's grumbling huh
what some muck grumbly mumbling yeah
burn out grumbling mumbling me all right
we're going much the same way that we
went before but I'm gonna go through it
as if I've never gone through it just in
case there's something different
happening are there cooties yeah so
awesome like crumbly Mobley's all right
whatever
yeah man first-day blues whatever all
right
reloading with goon not that I'm gonna
need it yeah come on rumbly tumbly x'
huh maybe I want tussle what's with
these hydrants these weren't here before
there definitely weren't there
definitely porn hydrants hmm huh weird
yeah it's not very good oh you so I'm
gonna happen I'm watching you
I don't think wait does not do anything
if you're not looking at it oh you dick
okay I'm just gonna ignore you
Oh real oh you're not gonna do you're
not gonna do some huh you want Russell
what dumb Ross out huh you wanna tussle
the muscle okay you did some all right
you listen listen why are you jiggling
it what why are you jiggling it let's
stop jiggling it stop it okay you're
done you're done right Jenko jiggle no
more you've done jiggling little wiggle
and the jiggle ain't gonna happen you
weird ah what is this
this for oh it's got a I see I see the
thing am I supposed to do something
about this
maybe the wooden planks oh the wooden
planks that I was collecting before
ah I'm not you're not gonna fool me this
time for a fool me once a fool on you
fool me twice fool for you hello thank
you
alright what else we got ooh oh oh yeah
that seems like something I was supposed
to do hey I got a map or good map screen
is useful for more than your current
location I can show you points of
interest in items that you have found
but haven't picked up yet okay good good
good good good good great oh you didn't
see nothing you didn't see nothing you
don't see nothing spicy spicy secret
dang
spicy secret oh hey buddy how you doing
friend whoa whoa like what no what what
am i oh oh he had ammo yeah alright
you're definitely dead all right
hey hey hey pal you would that's what I
thought
wait hang on this is also what I thought
I follow up thoughts to my previous
thoughts that you had that really does a
lot of durability damage to my knife
like that I don't like that it does so
much durability damage what am I gonna
do with all that durability damage
alright whatever
oh okay I know you're awesome
with my muscle okay I why did I do that
there was no point in doing that I don't
know why I did that
okay uses a gun powder I know what gun
powder does I know what it's for
I know what it's for I'll take that
I am okay I did that this is safe there
there's that guy there I don't have the
combination for the safe I got nothing
hey okay I shouldn't waste my ammo like
that but here I am wasting ammo just
like that rookies first assignment Leon
s Kennedy we're putting you on a very
special case for your first assignment
your mission is to unlock your desk -
the key to your success is in the
initials of our first names and put the
letters in it order of our desks there
are two locks one is make sure you get
them both oh it's so nice basically your
task is to remember your fellow officers
names but you figured that much out
right good luck Leon by the way it might
take a little work to get Scott to give
you a straight answer scrawled in the
corner between drops of blood be glad
you're not here rookie oh no okay well
that's sad all right well okay there's
two locks all right so I gotta get no no
no no no no no hang on can you stay down
for good please can you just stay down
for good okay so I got to get the desks
the names of the okay Marvin Braun aghh
Rita okay great Neil Elliot and I have
that okay what do we got three others no
weapons in no ammo and too many
skirmishes friendís officer Phillips
once suggested we escape through the
sewers apparently there's a secret
tunnel Russ trough before but now it's
not so bad
okay Eliot Edward officer Phillips
that's Eliot Edward so n e ne P and E
okay there's no P there we go Ned all
right and then this one was Marvin Rita
and blank okay there we go mr G okay
good yeah my desk hey that's for Matilda
I don't use Mattila but I'm not using
Matilda I got a suite special
oh you sack that was not always not you
all right oh that's nice
that's so sweet okay whatever I'm out oh
[ __ ] oh okay well I can't do that either
all right so there was no point of this
at all no need for any of that no need
no need there is no need I'm gonna get
one of these
I'm gonna get this even though I don't
have space in my goddamn thing cuz
they're uh they're a bunker-buster is
there a monkey yeah is a bunker-buster
okay
put this away put this away I'm gonna
put this away because I don't need it
maybe I should use Matilda yeah whatever
I'm not gonna do it and I'm gonna keep
that alright here we go
oh where is where is the the some where
is the code thing for the the weapons
Locker the shotgun unless they're not
gonna give that to me right away because
getting the shotgun that early might
have been just a thing for the demo and
not necessarily a thing for anything
else
might have been it cuz I think I
remember I would have gotten that by now
but apparently I don't have it so no
worries let me just store these all
right and then when we look at this save
our easy peasy and whatever this is
herbs herbs herbs herbs no important
alright hello goodbye oh there that goes
hey buddy I'm not gonna bother with you
oh hey hey friend hey yeah oh yes oh oh
yeah ah I remember
okay portable safe oh okay so I got a
portable safe
I guess interesting okay I get it
oh I like that it plays a nice noise
what did I get
oh it's simple it's [ __ ] I got a
bunch of [ __ ] I got a piece of
[ __ ] that's great I'm so happy about
that what is it Wow it's a keyboard key
it's the thing okay wait I know wait I
need to go back because I missed
something I missed the whole weapon area
that's right I did what hey don't do
that all right
I miss the whole weapon area I did I did
I did yeah oh it's locked
is that the whole weapon area you know
do you know about the weapon area
I missed uh some kind of a washer oh
listen hey buddy
oh no what who's there
okay yeah you guys stayed Oh laughs no
no no this this one this yeah the weapon
then this and put the key in use yes and
then I can get into 206 or 202
wait hang on okay ah 102 102 102 yeah
then I can get into 102 right it's just
that easy now I don't think I'm gonna be
able to get the uh I don't think I'm
gonna be able to get the shotgun just
right away because I don't think that
the game will let me get the shotgun
that right away it's not a camera thing
bullets in 109 perfect
easy man who knows we're never getting
bullets would be this easy can I have
those all right put those there
aw so many bullets love it Oh two or
three oh no oh that's gonna be hard
oh I need the button huh [ __ ] you smart
you smart okay 2:08 are you gonna be
like that huh can I have that back
please thank you I know it's almost
broken but I'm about to get another one
in 103 oh [ __ ] I can't do that you find
some spare keys ya find some spare keys
all right I'm gonna use this ahh I just
spray it on my wounds all better now
baby I can't get this cuz I don't have
the thing but that's okay because I
don't I don't think I was supposed to
get the thing alright
2:07 I can get to a seven at least yes
joy okay okay let's get it let's get you
out of here
that was almost not worth it almost not
worth it I mean it's kind of worth it
but it was almost not worth it I'm just
gonna go up and I'm gonna go ahead
because I'm sure that I'm gonna be
coming back here sometime soon before I
do that I'm gonna go and dump stuff off
at the locker and then I'm gonna say
okay say VIN let's do this alright so we
got to make our way back up we're still
looping back through the stuff we saw in
the demo so not too big I'm pretty sure
that the boards are for those windows
but I'm not gonna worry about the board
just yet I am gonna worry about the guy
that fell down I don't know where or how
but that guy fell now what do we get up
here hello thank you for that thank you
hello baby how you doing Oh oh yeah the
key ah
the key no the key I need the key that's
important so the key can unlock not only
the area head that I'm gonna come back
to but also the area down below you know
I'm gonna worry about it now you're
gonna worry about it because it's not my
problem because it was an area just down
here below that I could unlock and I'm
more interested in seeing all the nooks
and crannies that I had not gone to
that's weird art for a police station
then I am making sure that I blaze
forward in the story because I don't
want to miss nothing and I know then I'm
gonna miss stuff so don't mind if I go
one way or another she's just [ __ ] Lord
my supple neck my necks taken enough of
a beating already please my supple
delicious neck alright so if I do this
here out of being on a bingo what's in
here hey oh ah I meant i okay yeah
name's Claire I came into town with her
you can get to that courtyard the second
floor I'm on it thanks lieutenant
okay well also lieutenant I didn't know
that that it's just led right back here
I had a sneaky suspicion and I probably
should have known a little more about
that but I didn't know so so who where's
this guy you saw stop being such a dick
why these guys all dicks to me what are
you gonna be in the exact dick place
where dick a tree happens I can't be
nice I'm just trying to get a little
farther anyway whatever I'm sure I'm
gonna be going all over this police
station back and forth no matter what I
do so I'm not exactly worried about
missing out on something right here
right now
and also these combinations for these
goddamn coats they gotta be like there's
got to be like a localized little answer
or hint to the puzzle that says what it
is right it wouldn't just be blank I
don't know maybe it would be it was
there a scary thing those have
over here I don't remember somebody
please describe it to me hello to any
survivors consider this a gift
still fortunate unfortunate enough to be
alive keep your eyes peeled for those
creepy [ __ ] that look like they were
skinned alive lickers we call them
they're blind as bats but they're
hearing more than makes up for that as
long as you don't run around like a
total idiot guns a-blazing you should be
able to slip right by them properly
either way make like my grandma and
creep around as slow as possible right
anyway not that I want to go but duty
calls dead on I've got a friend to
avenge oh okay that's not good that's
what I would call not good I don't like
the sound of that I don't like the smell
that I don't like anything about that
okay okay
so do I need to worry about why for a
bit spooked by that you're not spook
rate twice I will not be double spooked
what's over here huh
where's this I've been here I've been
here and I've been you hello
I need yes hip pouch um I have a bunch
of fanny packs I'm gonna be the most
fanny pack guy in the history of forever
okay this is the c4 man I already know
about this
so there's c4 here but I don't have a
trigger for it so it's just gonna stay
there for now okay looks good looks good
looks good looks good okay all right
what do we got going on here some people
down there a real real swingy chandelier
maybe I could shoot that and drop it on
somebody
oh all right that's good to know what's
over here
he gods my egads I gods ye gods i
goodness gracious
I'll take whatever that is another knife
Thanks
where you got this I need that back at
some point your brain deflated can I
have my knife back or is that the only
now's the only knife I got okay all
right you have anything I need all right
cool
great good talk guys could talk what is
this I oh whoa it's a puzzle I know the
puzzle there's a journal there's a
journal okay
upper floors map good great good great
I've missed some stuff in there but
that's all right
okay good what is this gunpowder perfect
what's in here nothing hey listen you
don't need to do nothing about that I
need to read my journal
some all right here we go
notebook here we go ah this is the
unicorn fish lobster olive oil fish
lobster olive oil the fish lobster olive
oil there we go hey I got a unicorn
medallion which is perfectly normal
thing to have in a police station
perfectly normal Oh the party's here
Oh goodbye party parties goodbye your
goodbye there we go
oh wait oh come on that's very annoying
whoa what no whoa whoa I need some spray
yeah man this is harder than I thought
it'd be I'm out of spray I don't have
nearly enough spray who'd have thought
that I would have used up all my spray
this quickly oh I got one in the storage
I know that okay the trick of the day is
to not let them get that close because
that seems to be a stupid thing that I
constantly do and I need not to do is
hard it's hard guys hard all right so I
got a map there's an upper area I left
that there somehow
where is that where's that ah that was
on the body of the guy but I didn't want
to get too close to the body because I
thought that the body would have been a
bad thing to get close to okay I know
that now I need to go get some spray and
I'll get it eventually
oh yeah the lion the lion I forgot about
the lion okay the Lions right here well
that's easy
okay lion lion branch and bird
okay lion Hey all right cool what is
easier than I thought it'd be is so easy
what does that mean that this lady down
here is the other one or does it is this
where those things go probably where the
things go how are you doing you need
some spray all right good talk buddy hey
thanks for the encouraging words you
really always a bright shining light at
dark time so glad that you are the way
that you are all right I need to stop
being such an idiot and I need to get
this here I need to put that in put that
in put that in put that in and there we
go use art I'm all better
easy-peasy gonzo ones oh and stop being
bitten
that's the order of the day I just need
to stop being bitten so long as I can
stop being bitten I can stop being such
an idiot let me see if I can go up here
in the room over here it seems like it
might be open yeah cuz it seems like it
would be the way to Claire I think that
was the whole point of what I was being
told before so I'm gonna go try to find
Claire
we've officially reached the new area
okay so this is good but also bad
because I could possibly die horrible
death because I don't know what's coming
guide pamphlet ah block from the police
station is an orphanage I think probably
a bad thing I mean not saying the
orphanages are a bad thing but for me oh
[ __ ] okay well um there's the safe here
I don't know how to deal with it that's
it there's got to be something later on
the game that tells me the combination
for that but not here right now so why
do I even worry about it
Lukey hello hello
[Music]
um I'm gonna pretend like that didn't
happen and everything will be a-okay
I guess I'm just gonna pick this up now
okay now I'm in the realm of unknown and
I have a bad feeling that I don't know
what the hell's happening here Oh cranky
yank I don't have a crank or a yank
I think in the art room hello Wow I
don't know why a police station has an
art room like this but it's lovely the
Ruby that captivated Edward the Black
Prince the Pearl that the Queen of the
Nile milk dry the diamond that lead led
a queen to the guillotine there is no
end to the number of tales related to
the appeal of jewels this mysterious red
stone is simply the latest to Sparkle
among them okay is there a point oh hey
there's that thing that's what I was
looking for and there's that thing the
red ruby hey are you missing your arm
here okay all right well it's an easy
puzzle there you go buddy
easy [ __ ] okay easy peasy
mmm okay so I'm guessing something else
is supposed to be in that arm before I
can take out the red ruby key or the
scepter or whatever that is okay I don't
know but something's supposed to go in
that hand so I don't have it so I'll
move on let's not worry about it right
now we got something else to worry about
like the giant explosion that we just
heard that's probably a whole lot of
nothing but I'm gonna proceed as if it's
a whole lot of something and then yeah
I'll be good hello oh oh wow that's
that's really something
that is really a thing that happened
Claire hold on I'll be right there
okay whoa Oh problem Claire it's so nice
to see you how are you doing that
helicopter just over in one piece I'm
guessing you don't have a key in one of
those fancy pockets unfortunately no but
how are you doing you know just
surviving it's cute this is cute there's
really cute brother yeah yeah
clear don't lose hope I'm sure we're
gonna find him oh damn it know what that
means yeah
oh I did it
you take care of your stuff okay
I never worried you need to go now
through this both of us
this is gonna be so cool because it's
gonna be like two stories that we get to
play through oh hey you're not you're
not Claire I saw these Marvin do you
copy
Marvin
oh sweet oh sweet I can cut through
these now wait there was a bunch of
these back in the other areas I gotta go
back then I'll get there eventually
hello
oh no way oh no no no no way okay hang
on yeah this is you you wait right there
I gotta I gotta do some stuff hang on
scooby-dooby is that a greener herb and
on a mushroom left I have to chugalug
one of those down hey you're up and Adam
hey listen Bobby you don't need to do
this gun powder I'll leave it right
there I'll come back for it don't worry
I definitely will that's a lot of
bumping a whomping hey you thumping 1pp
thumpy Wampus oh that's important I need
fat I'll give up Adam okay
am i fine can I combine this in this Oh
oh that's probably a bad use of those
but I did it any oh I'm in trouble I was
great gunpowder oh boy oh boy okay can I
get out of here oh that doesn't sound
good
hang on it's not a fuse oh it's an
electrical part just as good as a fuse
all right hang on I need it mmm okay
need to do something thinking using my
big brain using my big brain oh [ __ ] all
right whatever
oh my big brain ain't gonna work let's
do this Oh big brain holy [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
all right
there is problem many problems Russia
many problems okay I promise you to read
up on them the herbal mixing guide
because I don't seem to remember exactly
what I was supposed to do and when I was
supposed to do it so Oh No what are you
doing here I'm gonna get you
yeah perfect
I need that back though oh [ __ ] I'm not
alive I'm not live my swords my knife is
good oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] dude I
thought two of them taking me down would
have been death for certain but okay I
don't I don't have anything to take what
is that stuff flash this doesn't help me
it doesn't help
what is but oh my knife that's right my
knife is gone okay can I drop that
awesome I'm gonna drop could I discard
but I don't want to discard it I don't
want to discard it I'm trying to okay
I'm just gonna gun through here above
gob we'll come back for it I'll come
back for you
I can't go back I can't go oh oh no oh
boy oh wow Oh wowie Zowie this is bad
holy crap okay um oh oh man Mamba Jamba
I didn't go the ride in and do this
right but there was there was ammo in
here I remember that I left some ammo in
here take that put that there with that
there to put turn this on and off on was
on on there was no point in coming here
okay alright we're all fine everything's
good this is great in fact it's so great
then I'm gonna come back around here
pick up the goddamn electrical part oh
hey buddy listen friend you need not be
here there we go finally a blown up head
okay electrical part that goes there I
need this here oh my god use it okay and
we're up
go go go go go go go go go go go go oh
my god okay uh listen buddy I may have
made a goofy
I may have goofed you might be about to
dead you might be about the dead friend
that you might be about to dead
i I mean you're obviously about to dead
because of the whole like horrible thing
in your side but you might be also about
to dead because it's just not good here
okay where did valve go let me think
about where odd the showers I remember
the showers right right right um if I go
through here ride right perfect if I go
through here and then jeez this is so
much harder than I thought it'd be this
is really quite difficult okay really
quite oh yeah the locker I gotta get to
Bhoomi gotta get the bang II get the
movie of a good position here oh but get
the boo me I'm gonna get the bang II and
then heads gonna go bye-bye and then I'm
gonna get what I need okay this is
perfect I love this I could have put
this there it is exactly as I was hoping
it would be able to move you buy them
and then Oh
easy peasy all right you okay we're good
reload you up oh yeah you want some of
this you want some of this you want some
of this huh is completely gone all right
oh that's not it exactly what else all
right let me get the shotgun shells out
of that cool all right now that I've got
a bit more umph to my boom I can
oh I can do a little bit better than
what I was doing before
okay so I'm not gonna go that way I'm
gonna go back and I'm gonna try let's
see okay that's not where I'm gonna go
where were that there were more chains
there more chains may be back this way I
don't remember I don't quite remember I
can't go nod this is a dead end
that's okay whatever oh that's right
[Applause]
okay god this is who's nerve-wracking
it's tense it's legit all right let me
read whoa hey buddy you you're right
you want some herbs or something you
okay you all right oh that guy's gonna
turn into a zombie that guy's definitely
gonna turn I'm a read up real quick on
herbs okay okay it doesn't say that but
let me look at gunpowder okay let me let
me combine no not that let me combine
some gunpowder here oh I don't have
enough room when you put this away let
me let me combine this okay red and
green herb okay and then we there we go
oh that's a lot of that's a lot of ammo
okay I'm gonna combine this two there
okay put this there combine these
perfect store that no not store that kid
then I'm gonna put this this combine
these two boom great no don't store
those put those away
all right this is good this is good this
is good okay save cuz we're not doing
great but we're doing okay man I'm torn
up yeah so what did that get me and what
do I need to do now I've got the cutters
so I can go there's gotta be something
that I can break open with the chains
maybe something back here because I
remember seeing chains no maybe that was
in the early area man whatever it
doesn't matter I think I remember seeing
some chains in here nobody no no the
valve ah whoa
whoa whoa easy there buckaroo knee Hey
been having more brain popping lately
which is good I guess I don't think I
want you're still jiggling I don't you
know I don't want to be here I'm gonna
go I'm gonna go around and up so I can
get to the valve thing later not gonna
worry about right now stop being such a
little [ __ ] Leon you really need to
stop being a [ __ ] Leon whoa Redbook was
the red book - what do I do with the red
book okay let's forget about the red
book for now oh never mind I'm sorry I
didn't know you were there didn't know
that room was occupied I'm I apologize
for everything that I've ever done in my
life
nice their brains are exploding lately
which is a good sign of guessing all
right put this here turn it shut off the
steam yes okay good now I don't know
what's going on in here okay oh hi you
just chilling you're right you okay whoo
all right the answer is yes you're doing
just fine
oh all right
hello gunpowder good hello nothing good
oh wait where where am I
where am I
not a hundred percent sure where I am
have I been here that's weird I thought
if I was this much above I am dead I
know I'm dead I thought but [ __ ] all
think was I was bowled over
alright fine then I guess weird I guess
that's I guess yeah I guess yeah that's
that's fine okay just gonna be net oh I
see you I see you okay so
just
okay all right okay just easy as pie
nothing to fear fears for the week and
the week is not what I am I low battery
I don't have any space in my inventory
internal memo 915 seven oh that's nice
that's a code that's a code okay um [ __ ]
resistant three number combination safe
move two stars office Oh from stars
office to west office one okay all right
so the one at West office one which I'm
not out ever since your where that one
is but after I'll find it okay thank you
for that so very kind of you oh oh I
need a dongle alright so I need a USB
dongle so once I find my USB dongle I'll
be able to do what I need to do where I
need to do it oh nice jacket oh nice
grenade I don't have space for that I
don't space for anything here there's
something that you want me to have I'll
gladly do it can I have this woo
first-aid spray you know I love that um
hang on a second oh oh I don't know what
that did but I think it was good
probably okay whatever can I combine
this with mine there we go and then use
that to move that no no no no examine it
combined with that easy okay and then I
can take this put it there then I can
spray myself bada bing bada boom easy
peasy probably a waste of spray because
I think a spray is probably a full heal
but you know
at this point I'm just I call it the me
being stupid tax it's just like I've
been stupid up into this point so that's
the tax that I need don't run
of course he's gone of course he's gone
oh that's a lot of blood on the walls
boy nice butthole I don't know how to
crouch there's a lot of clumping
happening not my my feet and your tuchus
is my god your tuchus is wonderful your
tuchus is just Wow nice move you you are
talented and I'm skub right I feel like
you're just flaunting it now and I don't
like that
alright you know what you're you're good
you're good
oh um oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy okay
alright I didn't doubt that this shotgun
wouldn't have blown you from kingdom to
come but um Oh what am I supposed to do
what do I do
[Music]
okay I'm not entirely sure if I'm
supposed to blast your ass
he got me yeah there I go okay if I had
a full load I wouldn't have taken a hit
there ah that's what they all say oh
really really I was just supposed to I'm
supposed to go slow
Hey
good to see ya how's the family
all right good to know can I just get
one more little Oh
that doesn't sound too good I'm doing
fine though so I guess it didn't hurt
that bad
bit of a body in the way okay I guess
that don't bother you none
Hey are you doing what what the what
what the hell that's insanity my mom oh
come on
seasons what a waste of bullets okay
what was even the point of going on that
way did I even get anything oh yeah I
need I got the combination safe to the
one west office great great great great
west office one wherever this is there's
a safe there great that's in the I know
where that is
I need to I know where that is okay I
know it is what a waste to waste of
everything I'm just a goddamn waste is
what I am oh okay so in here
oh I don't know what that was all about
but we've got to save okay left nine
right 15 left seven so 9:15 seven okay
hey there we go Oh a new fanny pack I've
been looking for you thank you so much
thank you very much thank you I
appreciate that and I appreciate you
alright so now I got a little more one
more carrying capacity which is always
good
well I went on a long detour to do
something that I thought it was gonna be
a lot easier than it was but it turns
out it was not so let's just get back on
track I need to put this away I got I've
got the herb mix here will fully restore
your health this blend of oh oh ah okay
so I'm gonna keep one of these on me
just to have that there I've got a book
I've got something I've got a bunch of
[ __ ] and I have no idea what to do with
it but that's okay alright so I need to
get to something over there
maybe the red book is maybe the red book
needs to go in the hand of the statue
for the red gem I mean they're both red
that's literally the only thing I have
to go on right now
well my sick brain is telling me that
that's probably something remotely close
to the truth and if it's not that I'm
stupid and I apologize for nothing
all right slam bam thank you ma'am
where did you come from and why and
don't even think about answering either
those questions cuz I don't care oh come
oh me that's what you get why are you do
you know what I don't need to know about
you I don't even want it all about you
can I have that hand please sorry can I
combine please tell me this is yes I
have a big brain brain Oh perfect give
me that [ __ ] give me this [ __ ] give it
to me give me that [ __ ] give it to me
there you go you stupid piece of crap
now I don't know
I don't know what this scepter is doing
in this place but I've got a scepter now
and I feel real good about myself I feel
real good I feel like this is supposed
to be this way you still there oh yeah
right no no no all right fall over why
don't you alright so I don't know if
there's anything else over here that I
needed well that's awfully exploding
does this hurt me seems like that might
hurt me but it's not hurting me so far
so I guess it's okay there was something
else out here that I forgot so I'm gonna
go get that on the board hey buddies you
still you alright alright good you stay
stay cool anything over here can I get
in there now alright this goes back down
here you you son of a [ __ ] No
okay you all right buddy we still good
you need some spray or whatever all
right was there something else in here
that I missed cuz I remember there being
other junk but I don't know if it was
vital okay and I've got this red scepter
and I don't know where the red scepter
would go hey hey hey hey
you shitlords need to get it together I
don't think there was anything else
all right good thing they they're afraid
of getting out that way good thing good
good thing huh all right so there's got
to be something else for this red
scepter now where would a red scepter go
hey buddy hey pal where you you know
anything about a red scepter okay all
right see you later okay let me take a
look at this thing oh oh oh would great
I think that's for what did I get I just
got a alright whatever sure there they
examine of this bolt cutter
very intense bolt cutter how about this
anything examine up here all right
whatever
examine this dump this in my eyeball no
nothing okay alright whatever whoa - Wow
- head splosions alright well they're
falling like flies okay so this one
still says red so I'm assuming that
there's something in here that I need I
mean besides the obvious of small items
but there must be something else in here
that is valuable because I'm guessing
that if it's red and it says it's
currently searching then there's got to
be something in the air of value that I
need and I feel like in my rush oh
alright
I'm big it used Hey look at that keep
the riffraff out okay riffraff street
rat I don't buy that all right whatever
okay I guess we're done here
never mind but that's good because that
says that what I need to do is I need to
search the rooms so that I can get what
I need to get which makes sense it makes
sense it does make sense what storage
room explose barricade I don't look okay
all right so let's go with that in mind
okay so I must have what I need to carry
on in some way shape or form there must
be something that I have that will allow
me to carry on I just don't know what it
goes to yet all right maybe I do know
what it goes through I'm just too stupid
to figure it out so let me come let take
these out real quick just because this
is something that I have and if I can
use it I mean that'll be good right I'm
probably good all right so you go use
all right oh oh look at that
- see there you go it's it did something
it may not have done everything that I
needed boy it definitely did progress a
little bit so maybe that unlocked
something else elsewhere just because
now that that's been a thing that can
actually be done you know what I mean
probably you know what I mean I'm gonna
cut through I'm basically gonna go
through this all again just to see if I
can find out where I need to go okay I'm
born in these up cuz I got nothing else
to do with them so I'm just gonna do
that oh hey buddy hey buddy
oh no can we not have this happen
all right just gonna do that and then
the riffraff is gonna stay out right
that's how the riffraff looks Oh where'd
you come from riffraff all right I've
already searched this area oh I knew
there was one more I knew there was one
more I knew it I knew it I knew there
was one more locker room c.a.p okay
that's good locker room see ap was
hoping for and so if I combine this with
the battery suddenly I've got a kaboom
er it makes sense it all comes together
it all comes together that's all coming
together see ap okay got that and then I
get another one of these because I'm
awesome and I can't open that but it
don't matter cuz I don't need to locker
room see ap flashy bang e alright it's
all coming up
markiplier that's what is coming up Oh
baby hello baby
listen listen listen listen don't don't
don't go okay locker room see ap that's
upstairs from here so let's go around
this is good it may not seem like good
but it is good this is good this is all
very good don't get up good enough
bullets and you already you better not
get up also somebody has my knife
somebody somewhere has my knife so I
don't know who and I don't remember
where but somebody has my knife so if
you can give that back at any juncture
that'd be great let me go kaboom this
three two one kaboom
alright and go Oh oh-ho yeah alright
this is by safe at bra safe
[Music]
yes you say uh-oh hello is that chastity
belt what is that oh you want oh I know
what you want oh no wait I don't know
what you want okay hey I need to know
what you want
officers notebook lady arrow snake you
got it oh lady oh oh [ __ ] there we go I
got the lady hey forget the maiden
medallion that's pretty good right okay
now what the hell is going on over here
Oh hmm that's problem okay let me make
sure that everything's out of here yeah
we're good
see if I can get around this [ __ ] you
can't that's right that's right that's
right that's right oh yes boy he's doing
a lictor on me all right this one's full
health right I'm good to go
you all suck I need to go to the locker
room to get to whatever was in the thing
which probably isn't gonna be worth it I
didn't know there was gonna be a liquor
I know there was gonna be a liquor I
didn't know there was gonna be a
liechtenstein huh son of a [ __ ] this
games kind of stressful so it's just
below me it's just blow me right down
here see ap okay it better be worth it
whatever's in here probably not worth it
okay see ay-yi here we go be good Wow
well good enough I guess all right well
that paid for the liquor I guess sure
I'll take it at this point I'll take
anything I'll just get out of here now
bored of this windmill I guess can I
board up this window there we go
easy-peasy no more riffraff
I said no more riffraff there anything
it okay well I'm just gonna go in here
save these guys are testing my patience
these guys are thinking that I've just
unlimited patience but it's not true
it's not true at all
all right I want to carry another one of
these on me just because I can
okay so I got the maiden medallion which
is a good thing I guess oh hey buddy I'm
not gonna I'm gonna I'm just gonna go
the other way I'm just gonna go the I'm
gonna go all the way around because I do
not want to deal with you Bob okay
hi buddy hey are you doing down there
you good
you got friend you good how are you
doing you feel good hey you better watch
this I'm about to do something cool this
hole are you watching Hey okay all right
you you watch here we go boom pretty
weird that this is part of our everyday
life as a police officer but you know it
is what it is this is way out could we
get out of here hey bunny hey Lois its
total freedom friend that looks safe
totally normal
that's it that's our way out
lieutenant brenna Marvin
Oh Oh it's time to go we need to get you
to a hospital right now
no no I save yourself come on I've got
you oh look we can still make it out of
here together
just it's too late I tried liad but I
couldn't stop it
we can't let this thing spread it's on
you now
just go
I understand
Oh
I won't let you down Marvin okay I won't
I won't do it Marvin you can't make me
let you down I ain't never gonna let you
down I ain't never gonna let you go
either I'm gonna remember this okay what
is this oh is that the mansion from
there's an evil one but it is gunpowder
that's good a typewriter this is nice
this is nice
looks like I'm gonna get out of here
with nothing bad ever happening again to
me never ever again I need more I need
more gunpowder I need more ammo yeah
that's not gonna be enough I gotta stop
what I got to stop doing this stop being
such an idiot about my ammo and just not
be as stupid about it what is that I
don't have that I don't have a crank
yank do I take it out of the thing above
that what I do I don't even think I can
get back right now
no not right now I'll get back
eventually but not right now
hello okay this seems
this seems normal just like a lot of
things in the city totally normal that
this exists oh boy oh I hate that oh I
hate that
[Music]
probably best take this nice and strong
why what was that
who's that who was that oh that's a
zombie maybe sounds kind of like a
zombie so I'm gonna go this is normal
yeah it's just normal to have under
ground of our police station
totally normal oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
oh yeah oh yeah is normal oh yeah okay
okay
this isn't so much a way out as just a
way oh hi Oh could you let me go how
about you let me go
look at the run now on the run let's go
run holy crap
no oh okay words won't work okay all
right sure yeah whatever
all right oh my god oh my god okay so I
guess the trick is to not get cornered
yeah oh oh I'm getting cornered
I'm getting immediately cornered oh boy
could you not do whatever you're doing
no choice gotta take it down I mean yeah
I wasn't choosing to do anything else
ah
look
nice I'm guessing the big glowing eye is
a weak point that's just my guess
oh hey okay this thing's so bad I can
just grab this ammo and be on my way
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] okay Oh Oh good
for me yeah well I mean it can't be too
far from where I just was so
okay bath what the hell Hey
yeah Oh No Oh
Jesus oh god I'm stuck
there we go come on come on do something
oh come on I'm not gonna have enough
ammo for this
hey hey get up
I don't think I got him I'm pretty sure
that's not getting him that probably Oh
handy that that's yeah yeah a little a
little bit too coincidental for my taste
but okay yes sure very handy that that's
a good thing I'm very happy about that
and whatever that was that just happened
can I get some good stuff that is not
nearly enough good stuff I was hoping
for like a much significantly higher
quantity of good stuff than the good
stuff that you're trying to give me
there was also some herbs down there
that I didn't get that I should probably
go get so I'm gonna go sweep the area
just real quick bill come right back and
you Inc and do I need a full I know how
to combine things combined I don't know
if I need a full heal but I'm getting a
full heal anyway just cuz I feel like it
oh I have no bullets I have no nothing
okay moving on I don't know where I'm
going next or who's looking at me well
this looks like okay
all right handy don't know why I needed
to do that why couldn't my benefactor do
that whoever's looking over for me but
okay
easy enough this place looks lovely sure
I'm glad that I am here alright
oh good it's safe room always feel happy
in these alright please give me some
good stuff oh that is some good stuff
that's so nice thank you I love my ham
fanny packs
alright oh please yes I now what I'm
realizing is that I probably shouldn't
have nearly used up all the storage
stuff that I have had in the past
and yeah Here I am so with nothing so I
hope I get something I hope I get a
little bit of something even though that
boss fight was nice and all but I hope I
get a little bit of something Oh
cutscene okay okay
[Music]
oh well I still seem to be in the police
station but at least I have the
potential for escape at this point maybe
oh those are fun sounds why are those
sounds being done oh I don't have a card
I don't have both
[Applause]
thank you who is that stay sharp
lower it
FBI perfect Oh perfect sorry thank you
your help
surprised you made it this far
uh-huh uh-huh what's going on here sorry
that information is classified
where you going do yourself a favor stop
asking questions and get the hell out of
here Wow
FBI huh oh my god FBI's here everybody
just talking to you okay goodbye you
know what I'm kind of done talking to
you I gotta talk to somebody else I
don't really feel like talking to you
anymore
Oh feel like talking to anybody actually
I'm kind of a loner so FBI is not really
any interest of me so I'll see you
around
All Right see ya maybe I was supposed to
follow her well I bet she would have
just locked the door behind her right
that's probably what it is right maybe
you know whatever maybe I'm not a loner
maybe I maybe I kind of I was missing
some company and any semblance of a
human might be nice to be around at this
point so oh okay oh okay
well got some bullets that's nice Oh
lady
oh the G hole ah I don't like this place
at all okay this seems bad all right
oh hi
Wow okay how you doing hi yeah okay good
good talk I didn't notice you there
all right oh boy hi okay all right
don't know what I was expecting why did
that lady go in here lady Lady please
don't oh hi hello hi hello human you
been here long long enough are we the
last ones alive no no there's a few of
us oh that's good news I guess yeah
that's of course I had sent you
irons you mean chief islands is he still
around who cares
hopefully he's somebody's dinner by now
what do you mean by that he's the
bastard that locked me in here I'm sure
he had a good reason he did I was about
to blow the whistle on his dirty ass how
did him the same thing to him I guess
whoa hey I'll make a deal
unlock this cell and I'll give you this
there's no other way out of that parking
garage
believe me sorry I can't do that I have
to talk to the chief first right both
prisoners in the station
so either we play nice and help each
other out Shh it's coming what what's
coming come on don't be an [ __ ] okay
you need this just give me the [ __ ] out
of here oh who is that it's just me no
what happened it just happened so quick
I told you to get out of here wouldn't
want to end up like Ben would you you
know him he was an informant had
information of use to my investigation
so what he said was true
hey you can't keep walking away from me
I don't even know your name I'm Leon
Kennedy I find a way out
Leon before it's too late
and we'll talk we're just gonna pretend
like it's alright ADA thank you well I
guess the deals on okay good great great
it's a good deal in the world
yeah we're just good it's like
everything that's fine that's fine
that's fine that whoa that this is fine
okay I see the puzzle here can I do the
puzzle but apparently not okay oh I know
where that goes
wait no I know where that goes okay Jail
power panel
we're gonna need of those custom power
panel parts clock tower all right blue
clock tower so you know the police
clock tower have their cups they've the
nervous hiccups pull this did a whole
lot of nothing okay
all right good to know it was it's just
death here hey friend this is nothing
but a whole bunch of death all good in
this neighborhood it's so happy free fun
where did that guy come from where did
he go was his name cotton eye Joe I
don't know all right back into the back
into the police station hey I know the
chief is chief of police chief Oh police
possibly might might be chief of police
nobody might be corrupt probably corrupt
this looks even worse than the other
place boy where am I
okay let me go this way first
that doesn't sound good
Hey look a red orbit blue blue or better
than red oh boy oh boy oh boy oh that's
not good oh that's not good that's
that's that those aren't gonna hold oh
oh these bags of kibble Oh what is this
place for a dog to crawl out of I
suppose oh boy oh just yay
Yahoo oh boy
none of this is good Oh none of this is
good none of this is good Oh none of
this is good
okay open her up where she goes alright
nothing in there
good great Oh
oh I can't waste a single bullet I
wasted a single bullet whoa
critical hit I go down please go down
please please just go down can you
oh my god that wasn't okay finally I'm
out of bullets
okay nothing you know what maybe not
maybe not oh that's handy dandy what if
I said I'm gonna be gonna plant in here
that's so sweet
that's Sona hey wait if I combine these
two it's extra conditional reduces
damage taken and guards against poison
for a short period I thought I thought
that was some different all right good
somehow I went to the one I needed first
I don't know how but I did that I'm just
that skilled at video games
all right poochie's can you stay in your
cages poochie's
can you boot these please stay in your
cage okay okay the pooches have stayed
in their cage the poochie's is and are
or have been stay in Cades hello
hello Behnke no longer usable or the
doors intro with keyless entry buttons
okay I'll box oh hello you know there's
there is no need message for mr. raccoon
okay
okay good ah no no please anything but
this anything but this horrible miss
don't please oh god no okay
I don't look good all right so let me
look at this let me examine there we go
hello Wow
oh this is what they were talking about
okay so I can use this to open up some
huh use this to open up some keyless
doors and trunks and maybe find some
extra ammo and or guns can I use no not
that this examine hey there we go whoa
what is that a gun stock for Matilda God
now I gotta use Matilda well I've really
got to use Matilda now yeah cuz I can't
use it with my super special
alright fine I'm gonna go use it on the
till then alright so small problem I
don't have enough bullets to get through
those two zombo's I don't have a knife
to get through those zombo's either else
I would do that I don't have Matilda so
I can't take advantage of this gun stock
or the extended magazine for Matilda
there in so I'm in a bit of a pickle and
there's two zombo's right through here
and I don't have to zombo's worth of
nothing so I am in turbo I'm in a big
turbo land but I would think I would
think
I would think that there would be some
kind of bullets Wow there would be
bullets in there somewhere in there okay
I can make that I can make this there
would be right it's a firing range of
course it would be of course there would
be oh hey that's handy
we have but let me look in here first
it's got to be bullets or something
right
what is this ah let me know [ __ ] [ __ ]
Frick ah oh babe do i maybe I don't need
this anymore maybe could discard that no
[ __ ]
okay ah but I need yeah all right um
I'll come back for it I I always know it
I I know it'll be here for me
when I need it not now no please do this
and then burst through there like oh
that's right I have one of those blow up
your brain never oh there they go
okay that's well now I don't need to do
that yet I need to go get help that blow
up your head how does that not blow up
your head help explain to me how that
doesn't blow up your head Oh imma blow
up your head
blam okay whatever
good enough good enough good enough good
enough I'm gonna take this that there
what is this that is very helpful
I guess combine oh [ __ ] bat [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] I need that don't do that haha
did that okay I have nothing good I know
I could probably drop this
it's got check mark by it all right I am
very reticent this is no maybe if I just
why did I have to pick up letter R you
know what it's just like I got I got a
drop it I just have to it has to be gun
cuz I need to get this I don't know what
the film oh I know what the film is I
know what the film does that I know
where to get the film to but I'm just so
full I need more fanny packs yeah all
right whatever I got that so that's good
I got that so now what okay so I need to
go there's something in the kennel that
I haven't seen yet which is
understandable I don't want to go back
to the kennel but the kennel is where I
got to go the poochie's are gonna behave
the pooch is gonna be nice they're gonna
be so nice the pooch is gonna be nice
and good and oh my god
Oh was this Frick Frick you combined
there yes perfect oh that was it
apparently okay that was it apparently
that was it that was all I needed that
was it
okay that was it all right cool great it
really is just say from or a safe word
something safe I don't feel safe can I
put this near
oh if I'd known about that I woulda done
that a long time no oh oh where does
this lead please tell me it leads to a
safe room where I can have like op like
a chest chest this doesn't look like a
place with a chest oh that doesn't sound
good
was this gunpowder I'll leave it there
for now oh this sounds this is a bad
place oh this bed or not
Oh
okay did I do it
oh I know it it's a puzzle there we go
hey goody goody gumdrops oh I stopped
good oh that's not good
oh hi god oh my god no god dammit don't
make me waste this I will kill you okay
you better stay down I hate you I hate
you I hate all of you who what's this Oh
box electronic parts that's what I
needed for the thing Hey look and herb I
can't get that I couldn't possibly get
that oh great I don't have enough
bullets for that oh boy okay all right
ah no please I'm running away from him
just let me ride I don't want anything
to do with anything I'm very slow
oh no okay this is not the right way
wait no I need to do Oh God
here you go this way oh god oh god oh
god oh my god hey go this way
okay last one one more that's all I need
sorry baby okay alright we're good we're
good
I don't know where this is gonna go but
we're good we're good we're good baby
we're good back in the police station
safety all right all right
can I please thank you my god okay so
there we have it
that is all the time I have for the
first episode of this game thank you
everybody so much for watching look
forward to more big long episodes every
other day until this game is done I am
making my progress through it it's very
scary it's very good I like it a lot I'm
going back to Matilda and I'm going to
combine Matilda up Matilda's looking so
good nowadays look at Matilda go what a
great gun what a great that is too big
god damn it it's big why is it big Oh
but anyway thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video
[Music]